-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're
doing well tonight
and now, we're going
to get to the news.
Vice President Kamala Harris
spoke yesterday
at a gala for a pro-abortion
rights organization and said,
"Those Republican leaders
who are trying to weaponize the
use of the law against women,
well, we say, how dare they."
Great.
That oughta do it.
[ Laughter ]
And, if that doesn't stop them,
you can always throw in
a "Harumph?!"
[ Laughter ]
Microsoft co-founder Bill Gates
spoke out yesterday
against the potential reversal
of the Supreme Court's decision
in Roe v Wade
and warned that it would
"set us back 50 years."
He said the next time America
makes that much progress,
we should remember to hit save.
[ Laughter and applause ]
In a new interview,
Maryland Governor Larry Hogan
said that former President Trump
should not run for reelection
and added that Trump is
"enjoying playing golf
five or six day as week."
Why ruin that
by going back to a job
where he could only play
four or five days a week?
[ Laughter, cheering,
and applause ]
President Biden is set to hold
a Cinco de Mayo party tomorrow
at the White House,
because what's more fun
than a Cinco de Mayo
party thrown
by someone who doesn't drink?
[ Laughter and applause ]
That's like having
a Halloween party
and saying, "But FYI,
this is a no-sugar house.
Who loves raisins?!"
[ Laughter and applause ]
NASA is planning on sending
naked images of humans
into space
as part of a new mission
to communicate
with alien civilizations.
Guys, you can't do that.
At the very least,
you have to hit them
with a "U up?" first.
[ Laughter and applause ]
And, finally,
the NFL announced today
that the New York Giants
will play a game
against the Green Bay Packers
this season in London.
So, instead of losing
27 to nothing,
the Giants will lose 27-nil.
[ Laughter and applause ]
And that was a monologue,
everybody!